[Music]  it's 20 years since the moon was hit  electricity for only an hour a day  barely any food and all you care about  is cozmo  attention unregistered teleportation  his power is unbelievable beyond  anything i have seen  all we have is now i like you  i waited for this stepping in here makes  everyone nervous  fear not the game is more dangerous than  it may seem  all the hardships earth faced are a  result of the war with cherno  we're about to go play football with  what's essentially a nuclear bomb  and everyone else thinks this is just a  game  is that right pretty much it yes  it's easier to risk your life when you  know you're supported by millions  even if they don't know the truth or  understand risk  four young earthlings with incredible  powers  you show there is something to be  inspired by here we go  [Music]  [Music]  you